girl hey danny good to see you
congratulations on your new magazine
i would always tell danny how much i
loved his magazine and i would talk and
talk and talk and go you know an awful
lot about
magazines too much now the cat's out of
the bag i realized you were picking my
brain
i'm just coming to join forces with you
like in the magazine world on the show
i'm very lucky to be a partner with you
i love what you do
you make the world a better place let's
do this oh feelings mutual well today
we're going to make one of my favorite
recipes it's a no-bake
dairy-free gluten-free totally
plant-based
orange marmalade cheesecake it's
delicious but it's so easy to make
oh my gosh i everything you just said
got me excited
so first and foremost you need you can
put this in a springform pan just like
this or you can get little cups whatever
you have
and we make the simple crust it's just
uh pecans
and dates and dates are sticky you know
and so it's that stickiness
perfect binder when it's binding with
pecans and then you just press it into
the pan and that's all you have to do
again no bake
and then your next step is you need the
most beautiful blender you can find
by the way you know what i'm going to be
proud of is the blades
really kick butt in this thing should we
find out oh yeah
okay so we're going to make the filling
and what you need
is two cups of soaked cashews yeah just
put the soaked nuts into the blender two
cups
two types of extract we've got vanilla
extract and orange extract so that's an
orange flavor we really love then we
have a good fat
this is half a cup of coconut oil
so it's nice and warmed up some water
and so i believe this is
half a cup of water it's so easy half a
cup of maple syrup or you could do agave
syrup whatever sweetener that you want
danny maple syrup is so hot right now
it's and it's good for you
it's the real deal it's amazing on that
map
orange juice one orange
and then we blend away okay i'm excited
for you to see the power of this thing
[Applause]
yeah this is beautiful yeah love it so
the smell of this danny is exquisite
really nice and then we're gonna pour it
into our springform pan
and then drew the way that it sets up is
that you freeze it
oh so in about an hour it's gonna freeze
up really beautifully and you have this
over here
and then you can add a little orange
marmalade right on top if you want to
drizzle that
which is so yummy right here and a
little drizzle
oh my gosh i'm not good
oh no see this is how i gained 10 pounds
no but this is healthy
lots of protein there's no dairy it's
gluten free
it's got the sweetness from the dates
the reason i love it so much
is because of the taste the flavor but
the texture
is just velvety and luxurious and
creamy it's cheesecake it's cheesecake
i love that you actually do love food i
love it so much
i love it too much but
you know listen man
everyone has their thing and
i think it's the most romantic thing
that we do
and create and share and make i am i'm a
food girl
and i also know drew that we can't sit
around a table right now you know with
your audience at home but
um can i do a segway is that okay uh you
can do a segway because i like where
you're going
because i have i have a surprise for
your virtual audience but um
what i i've partnered with qvc it
launches
today you know for earth month not for
april fool's day
[Applause]
but we are i'm creating a new program
where i'm curating my favorite
clean beauty products i'm sourcing them
from all over the world i'm not the
founder i'm not the creator of these
products
it's sort of like our best of beauty
from naturally danny co
and it launches today lots of videos
tutorials and
i love qvc i shop at qvc and i thought
for your virtual audience
yes everyone in your virtual audience is
getting a 100
qvc gift card
how much do we love that i have to say
when i read about this danny
this felt really um not only revelatory
but relevant
yeah this to me is a real hook for me
with
i've always loved qvc they by the way
i've always pitched myself to them they
know how much i love them
um i think this is important
and we have got to take care of
ourselves and we have got to take care
of this planet
and uh you doing this is news
big news for me as a consumer out there
trying to do the right thing
i i love this thank you drew i really do
and i think
this is a real match my eyes went like
what when i read that last night oh i'm
so excited and i have found things from
all over the world that will blow your
mind it's clean
it's green they work well thank you
danny oh my gosh
we almost forgot the most important part
you can use
all of these orange peels to make an
amazing cleaner
this gets me hot and bothered because
i think you know how i feel about
cleaning and stains like
organizers and people who are
in the stain removal world those are my
rock stars
so go to our website and get the recipe
for that secret stain remover
you